Paying a fee to check luggage has become a
routine part of air travel
but it wasn't always this way.
In The United States, baggage fees started
in 2008,
right around the time oil prices were peaking.
“Another day, another dollar"
“Crude oil broke another record"
“We’re going to go from a profitable year
in '07 to a ten billion dollar loss in '08
and the only thing has changed is fuel.”
"Jet fuel prices have them taking drastic measures..."
"Including a fifteen dollar charge for the first checked bag."
"Fifteen dollars? Holy cow! I'll have to put my underwear in my pockets!"
To avoid the new fees, passengers started
cramming everything into their carry-ons.
But two years ago fuel prices dropped and
they’ve stayed low ever since.
The fees, however, haven’t gone anywhere.
The only exception among major carriers is
Southwest Airlines, which is famous for their
“bags fly free” marketing campaign.
"We duffel bags, golf bags, small bags..."
"These bags right here, they fly free!"
"I wouldn't pay to fly in here."
"Why would these airlines charge for bags?"
"Why do you charge for bags?!"
To make money.
Lots of money.
Last year, revenue from baggage fees was nearly
4 billion dollars.
And the 7.5% excise tax that airlines have
to pay on ticket prices
doesn’t apply to baggage fees.
So the tax code actually encourages the use
of fees.
And they haven’t stopped at checked bags.
With carry-on space now increasingly scarce,
airlines can charge a fee to board early so you can claim spots in the overhead bin.
Revenue from the fees, combined with other
factors like major mergers, have meant higher
profits for airlines.
But what’s good for the airlines has not
benefited consumers...
Airlines haven’t lowered airfares in proportion
to higher profits.
The planes are filling up anyway, so they
don’t need to compete on fares.
And all those carry-on bags are contributing
to longer lines at airport security.
This summer, passengers were stuck at two,
three, and even four hour lines at airports
across the country.
In response, a group of senators and the head
of Homeland Security asked the airlines to
waive baggage fees.
"We've asked the airlines to consider possibly eliminating the checked baggage fees."
"There has been an increase in the carry-ons due to these fees."
So, isn’t it time to get rid of baggage
fees?
Well...there’s more to the story.
A recent study has revealed a major benefit
to consumers that came from baggage fees:
better on-time performance for all airlines.
According to the research done by a group
of business school professors
charging fees to check two bags decreases the average departure delay by two minutes.
What they found is that the increase in luggage above the cabin has not off-set the reduction below the cabin.
Although it seems like carry-ons make the
boarding process longer, down on the ground
the airlines are handling fewer bags.
When you carry your own bags between connecting
flights, that’s work they don’t have to do
and it seems to be saving time overall.
That means fewer flight delays and fewer missed
connections.
There’s also been a decline in the number
of lost bags.
So, when it comes to baggage fees, it’s
not all bad for airline consumers.
It’s just mostly bad.